the proposal strengthens criminal law
instruments to achieve this traveling
abroad for the purpose of terrorism or
organizing or otherwise facilitating
such travel will become punishable
receiving training for terrorism and
financing of terrorism also becomes a
punishable act throughout Europe and
victims of terrorism receive the same
rights everywhere we need modern
contract rules for the digital age both
consumers and entrepreneurs benefits
from new European rules for the supply
of digital content such as purchasing
software music and movies on the
Internet once in effect the directive
will ensure a common EU response to the
phenomenon of foreign terrorist fighters
it will help us to prevent preparation
of attacks across the European Union and
it will sanction severely the
perpetrators IT companies upon
notification will take down any content
that constitutes public incitement to
violence and hatred based on race color
religion national or ethnic origin in
accordance with EU and national law
second IT companies will respond
promptly to review and takedown notices
third IT companies will have access to
civil society partners that will provide
them with high-quality removal referrals
for hate speech content I remain
confident that our common objective to
set up an independent efficient and
useful ap PPO will be achieved by the
end of this year